[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Christian Sievers dieser Donnerstag im
Nachrichtenüberblick guten Abend ihnen
allen Kristin ist hier und steuert den
sportball mit Gold guten Abend und wir
beginnen die Themen des Tages mit der
katastrophalen Situation die Einwohner
und Urlauber in Südeuropa umtreibt
Inferno am Mittelmeer nach mehr als
einer Woche extrem Hitze brechen in
Griechenland und der Türkei neue Feuer
im Stundentakt aus
Angriff im Netz Cyberkriminalität trifft
inzwischen neun von zehn deutschen
Firmen Milliardenschäden Tendenz stark
steigend
Triumph im Freiwasser Florian Wellbrock
schwimmt über 10 km allen davon und holt
olympisches Gold
aber zunächst die Lage in den
waldbrandgebieten in Griechenland und
der Türkei wo zur Verzweiflung der
Menschen zunehmend Wut kommt
Griechenlands Regierungschef Kyriakos
stimmt seine Bürgerinnen und Bürger auf
weitere schwere Tage ein das Land stehe
vor einer noch nie dagewesenen
Umweltkrise sagte er
gucken wir uns das einmal genauer an die
Feuer wüten seit Tagen nun sind schwer
unter Kontrolle zu bringen extreme Hitze
und Trockenheit haben sich im
Mittelmeerraum festgesetzt besonders
dramatisch sind die Brände in den
Küstenregionen in Griechenland und der
Türkei pablose
bis auf wenige Meter fressen sich die
Flammen in den Hügeln bei Bodrum an ein
Kohlekraftwerk heran tausende Tonnen
Kohle lagern hier die Anwohner wurden
vorsorglich mit Schiffen evakuiert doch
die Katastrophe bleibt aus in letzter
Minute gelingt ist der Feuerwehr den
Brand unter Kontrolle zu bringen
aufatmen können die Menschen nicht immer
wieder brechen neue Feuer aus
ähnliche Bilder auch auf der anderen
Seite der Ägäis hier ist besonders Evia
getroffen seit einer Woche schon wütet
das Feuer hier
auch bar Besitzerin maria karamuza hat
mit den Folgen zu kämpfen
das Problem ist dass unser Dorf
verbrannt ist und das bedeutet für uns
das Ende das ist das Problem
erst in diesem Jahr hat Maria karamuzza
ihre Bar eröffnet die steht zwar noch
doch wer soll nun kommen in einem Ort in
dem fast kein Stein mehr auf dem anderen
geblieben ist
auch Italien und der Balkan sind von
starken Bränden betroffen die Feuer in
Südeuropa sind ebenso wieder Starkregen
in Mitteleuropa Teil eines
wetterphänomens das auch mit dem
Klimawandel zu tun hat feststeckende
wettersysteme führen zu Extremwetter
also wenn sich Hochs und Tiefs nicht
mehr bewegen dann bleibt das Wetter vor
Ort und dann kann es eben zu langer zu
lang anhaltenden Regenfällen kommen oder
wiederholten Gewittern oder eben zu
heftigen Hitzewellen sowie in der
Südtürkei und in Griechenland Entwarnung
gibt es nicht für Freitag melden die
griechischen Behörden erneut höchste
Feuergefahr
der Wald ist essentiell für unser Klima
schauen wir auf den in Deutschland wo es
an vielen Orten nicht gut aussieht im
vergangenen Jahr sind in Deutschland so
viele Bäume gestorben wie noch nie
138.000 Hektar Wald wurden zerstört eine
Fläche etwa doppelt so groß wie Hamburg
schuld sind Trockenheit Stürme und die
massive Ausbreitung von Borkenkäfern
heute gab es einen privatorganisierten
waldgipfel wichtigstes Thema wie muss
der Wald der Zukunft aussehen Susanne
Gellert
Waldumbau Nachhaltigkeit Klimaschutz der
nationale waldgipfel will nachholen was
aus Sicht der organisierenden die
bisherigen waldgipfel der
Bundesregierung nicht geschafft haben
ich würde sagen hey lass uns doch mal
eingestehen dass es nicht funktioniert
und es funktioniert wird auch nicht mit
eingeführten neuen Baumarten
funktionieren so nach dem Motto
deutschland sucht den superbaum nein das
wird nicht funktionieren aber Wald vor
unser Haustür zeigt uns ständig hey ich
kann es noch und wir sollten ihn endlich
lassen das sehen zum Beispiel Teile der
Forstwirtschaft anders tatsache aber ist
noch nie ging es dem deutschen Wald so
schlecht inzwischen sind fast 80 Prozent
der Bäume geschädigt Wald Erhalt vor
wirtschaftlichem Ertrag das war eine
wichtige Botschaft der Runde aus
Wissenschaft und VertreterInnen von
Regierung und Opposition
Forstwirtschaft soll ja ihren Raum haben
ich sage nur nicht mehr Holz aus dem
Wald nehmen als dass der Wald ist
vertragen kann also wenn wir so stark
einschlagen dass sobald dadurch in den
nächsten Jahren in die Binsen geht dann
ist ja nichts gewonnen die Förster am
Donnersberg in Rheinland-Pfalz
entwickeln bereits den Wald der Zukunft
kein Kahlschlag keine Aufforstung der
Wald soll sich selbst erneuern mit
heimischen Arten je mehr Baumarten hier
sind desto geringer ist das Risiko dass
Katastrophen in der Zukunft diesen Wald
in der Summe gefährden dann sterben
vielleicht einzelne Baumarten wie jetzt
hier die Tanne oder die Buche aber
andere können an den Platz treten und
diesen Lebensraum für den Wald weiter
nutzen es sind neue Konzepte die der
Wald dringend braucht
in vier Tagen sprechen die
ministerpräsidentinnen und
Ministerpräsidenten mit Kanzlerin Angela
Merkel wieder über den künftigen
corona-kurs diesmal vor dem Hintergrund
dass die Zahlen zwar auf niedrigem
Niveau sind allerdings seit Wochen
stetig steigen was tun also vorher
Herbst und Winter soll es
Einschränkungen geben für nicht geimpfte
wie sie der Gesundheitsminister
vorschlägt die Diskussion darüber ist
voll entbrannt Christiane hübscher
wer darf künftig wo noch rein Tag 2 der
Diskussion und Bundesgesundheitsminister
Spahn liegt nach in einem Interview für
Diskus Stadien oder Theater also
Bereiche die nicht zur Grundversorgung
gehören kann ich mir auch einen Zutritt
nur für geimpfte oder genesene
vorstellen
abgestimmt im Kabinett hat Spahn das
nicht die Bundesjustizministerin von der
SPD findet seine Pläne in diskutabel und
der Start allerdings eingreift wenn der
Staat solche Vorschriften macht dann ist
das ein Eingriff in zahlreicher
Grundrechte und es muss immer
verhältnismäßig sein wir haben momentan
eine Inzidenz von 19 bundesweit und da
stellt sich schon die Frage ob diese
Diskussion jetzt die richtigen sind das
impftempo stockt aber deshalb ungeimpfte
vom öffentlichen Leben ausschließen und
Tests ab Oktober kostenpflichtig machen
nicht nur spd-länder-chefs auch die
Opposition hält das für falsch wenn man
Druck ausübt dann ist es eine Tatsache
des Lebens dass es dann sofort auch
Gegendruck gibt und ich weiß nicht ob
wir uns damit Gefallen tun zumal nicht
geimpfte ja jetzt schon erhebliche
Nachteile haben wir hatten das für eine
absolute Frechheit es zeigt sich dass
die Bundesregierung die eigene
Bevölkerung anlügt man dann immer davon
gesprochen dass es keine indirekte
Impfpflicht gibt jetzt taucht dieses
Papier auf und genau das ist geplante
indirekte Impfpflicht die Menschen unter
Druck zu setzen so dass alle sich impfen
lassen müssen der Ethikrat lehnt aktuell
eine direkte Impfpflicht ab aber wer
sich nicht impfen lasse müsse dann auch
mit den Folgen leben diese Person die es
nicht möchten müssen dann aber auch
damit rechnen weil sie ja eventuell
andere mehr gefährden dass sie dann eben
vielleicht auch bestimmte Rechte nicht
ganz so schnell zurückbekommen wie
andere Person droht die zwei
Klassengesellschaft am Dienstag will
Kanzlerin Merkel mit den Länderchefs
beraten wie weiter im Herbst
wir bleiben in der Politik mit
Blickrichtung Bundestagswahl hat der
Bundeswahlleiter heute eine Entscheidung
getroffen die für die Grünen bitter ist
die Landesliste der Partei im Saarland
bleibt von der Wahl ausgeschlossen mit
der Zweitstimme GRÜN WÄHLEN ist dort
also definitiv nicht möglich der
Bundeswahlleiter sagt die sargrünen
hätten beim Erstellen ihrer Liste gegen
das Demokratieprinzip verstoßen dazu
müssen wir noch mal reden und zwar mit
Theo call in Berlin guten Abend Theo was
heißt denn das jetzt konkret für die
wahlaussichten der Grünen wenn sie im
Saarland nicht als Liste zugelassen sind
also auf den ersten Blick könnte man
sagen was soll's die Sage Rüden haben
bei der letzten Bundestagswahl weniger
als 0,1 Prozentpunkte zum Ergebnis
beigetragen aber das könnten bei einem
Kopf am Kopf rennen die entscheidenden
Stimmen sein 2017 bekamen die Sage
grünen über 35.000 Stimmen diesmal
versprechen die Umfragen ja noch mehr
und wir erinnern uns 2002 waren nur 6000
Stimmen entscheidend für den Wahl
gewinnen also ob Schröder oder Stoiber
Kanzler wurden der Ausschluss der sehr
grünen muss nicht wichtig werden aber er
könnte es werden und das ganze macht
zudem deutlich wie zerstritten der
Landesverband der sargrünen ist und dass
die offensichtliche Einmischung der
bundesgrünen die Lage eher noch
verschlimmert hat und ihnen jetzt einen
weiteren Ansehensverlust beschert Theo
herzlichen Dank für diese Analyse
unser nächstes Thema heute abend
Angriffe die lautlos und verborgen
geschehen aber trotzdem folgend schwer
sind Angriffe per Computer auf
Unternehmen
cyberdiebstahl Spionage Sabotage dadurch
entsteht der deutschen Wirtschaft ein
Schaden von
223 Milliarden Euro jedes Jahr eine
Summe die sich zuletzt verdoppelt hat
und neun von zehn deutschen Unternehmen
sind schon attackiert worden besonders
mit erpressungssoftware Frank Buchwald
Martin Schäfer traute seinen Augen nicht
seine Firma aus dem Westerwald stellt
Trennwandsysteme her 120 Beschäftigte
klassischer Mittelständler von einem Tag
auf den anderen aber funktionierte kein
Computer mehr wir hatten keine Daten
mehr wir wussten nicht welche Aufträge
wir haben welche Kunden wir haben unsere
Maschinen liefen nicht mehr also unser
Betrieb war vollständig lahmgelegt
Cyber crime fast jede Firma hatte schon
getroffen digitale Kriminalität
explodiert der digitalverband BITKOM
schlägt Alarm
zusammengefasst reden wir hier über
einen Schaden von sage und schreibe
223 Milliarden Euro das ist mehr als
doppelt so viel als von vor zwei Jahren
wo die bei 100 Millionen mehr als
viermal so viel als vor vier Jahren also
wir sehen hier ein deutliches Wachstum
oft geht es um Firmengeheimnisse
Sabotage oder um Lösegeld das nationale
Cyber-Abwehrzentrum kämpft zwar gegen
die Hacker die aber sitzen nicht selten
im Ausland manche gar mit staatlichem
Auftrag
oft ist der Unterschied zwischen
staatlichen und nichtstaatlichen
Akteuren allerdings auf den ersten Blick
nicht zu erkennen Komplexität und
Zielrichtung des Angriffs bieten hier
allenfalls einen Anhalt dafür mehr aber
auch nicht Martin Schäfer hat die
Attacke schließlich selbst abgewehrt mit
Hilfe von Krisenmanagern und IT-Experten
wir sind mit dem Datenverlust von
ungefähr 20 Prozent aus der ganzen Sache
rausgegangen aber wir haben kein
Lösegeld gezahlt und konnten trotzdem am
Ende weiter produzieren Schäfer wünscht
sich auch deshalb mehr Hilfe gegen
Hacker eine Art Feuerwehr vielleicht im
Internet
und jetzt in der Sendung ein Thema das
uns hier betrifft und sie alle als
beitragszahlerinnen und Zahler das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat angeordnet
dass der Rundfunkbeitrag erhöht wird um
86 Cent im Monat damit folgten die
Richter den Argumenten von ZDF ARD und
Deutschlandradio die Entscheidung aus
Karlsruhe ist gleichzeitig eine ruhige
für Sachsen-Anhalt das als einziges
Bundesland die Anhebung zum
Jahreswechsel blockiert hatte über
folgende Entscheidung und Reaktionen
jetzt Birgit Franke
Kernpunkt der Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts eine Änderung
des rundfunkbeitrags können nur alle
Bundesländer gemeinsam beschließen
Sachsen-Anhalt darf die anderen nicht
blockieren
erfüllt ein Land seine Pflicht zur
Mitwirkung an der Rundfunk Finanzierung
nicht so liegt darin eine Verletzung der
Rundfunkfreiheit das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hebt in seiner
Entscheidung die Bedeutung des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks gerade
in Zeiten von Fake News und
Desinformationen hervor die
Beschwerdeführer begrüßen die
Entscheidung auch das ZDF
sie sichert die Unabhängigkeit des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks und
ermöglicht uns auch künftig ein
attraktives Programmangebot für alle
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer zu machen
Ministerpräsident Rainer Haseloff
akzeptiert die Entscheidung ist sich
aber nicht sicher dass das Parlament von
Sachsen-Anhalt zukünftig zustimmen wird
wir hätten uns wie gesagt vom
Verfassungsgericht hier erhofft dass man
aus diesem aus dieser Dilemma Situation
herauskommt dass dieser gordische Knoten
aufgelöst wird dass es leider nicht der
Fall gewesen weil Sachsen-Anhalt nicht
abstimmte setzt karlsruhe den neuen
Beitrag nun selbst vorläufig in Kraft
das heißt wir müssen nicht erneut 16
Landesparlamente damit beschäftigen
sondern es kann jetzt gestartet werden
die Koordinatorin der Rundfunkkommission
erwartet eine Beitragserhöhung
spätestens Ende des Jahres
dann gucken wir uns diese Entscheidung
doch mal juristisch noch ein bisschen
genauer an mit Christian Deka aus
unserer rechtsredaktion Christian hallo
jetzt gibt es ja auch Kritiker die sich
einen komplett anderen
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk wünschen
hat das Verfassungsgericht auch denen
einen Weg aufgezeigt das Gericht hat in
dem Fall klar gemacht dass der Weg von
Sachsen-Anhalt so nicht geht also ein
Bundesland kann nicht die Entscheidung
komplett blockieren wenn es um die
Finanzierung des öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk gehts geht dann muss immer
Einigkeit herrschen das heißt alle 16
Bundesländer müssen gemeinsam Stimmen
und einen weiteren Punkt hat das Gericht
klar gemacht die Politik darf zwei Dinge
nicht miteinander vermischen zum einen
die Finanzierung des Rundfunks und zum
anderen die Frage von Reformen die
Politik kann den öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk natürlich reformieren
prinzipiell aber sie darf an dieser
Stelle eben nicht die Frage der
Finanzierung vermischen damit dann noch
was sehr interessantes heute in der
Entscheidung aus Karlsruhe neben der
Geldfrage ging es auch um
Grundsätzliches was soll der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk den
Autorinnen und Zuschauern denn
garantieren aus Sicht der Richter das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat die
zunehmende Bedeutung des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks für die
Demokratie noch mal ganz stark betont
das gelte besonders in diesen Zeiten in
denen es Desinformationen gibt in denen
es viele verschiedene Informationen aus
verschiedenen Quellen gibt das
Bundesverfassungsgericht schreibt in dem
Beschluss von Deep Fakes von Fake News
von filterblasen das sind Begriffe die
man also so oft jetzt auch noch nicht in
Entscheidungen des Gerichts gelesen hat
und die Politik muss eben die Grundlage
dafür schaffen dass der öffentlich
rechtlich Rundfunk seinen Aufgaben
nachkommen kann und das geht nur wenn es
wenn die Bundesländer eine gemeinsame
Linie finden interessante Entscheidung
Christian herzlichen Dank für diese
Analyse heute Abend und damit zu unserem
nächsten Thema hier in der Sendung der
Blick in die Hochwassergebiete in
Rheinland-Pfalz werden auch in dieser
Woche immer noch Menschen tot geborgen
17 gelten weiter als vermisst dort und
in Nordrhein-Westfalen dreht sich alles
um das wie weiter in NRW gehen in knapp
zwei Wochen die Sommerferien zu Ende da
drängt die Frage wie das funktionieren
kann Schule im Katastrophengebiet
Dominik Müller Russell war in Schleiden
in der Eifel
jeden Tag packen sie an die Lehrerinnen
und Lehrer der Astrid Lindgren
Förderschule so schnell es geht die
schlimmsten Schäden beseitigen und
reparieren wer weiß ob das bis zum
Schulstart klappt irgendwer muss es ja
machen jetzt muss ja erstmal alles
wieder rausgerissen werden aufgebaut
werden der schuhbetrieb geht in zwei
Wochen los aber wir wissen gar nicht ob
wir Strom haben und also Internet oder
sowas sowieso nicht funktionieren aber
wenn es im Grunde haben wir jetzt noch
keine Ahnung in den tief gelegenen
Räumen wird kein Unterricht stattfinden
können so vieles klar also Ausweichen in
den ersten Stock oder sogar in eine
andere Schule die noch Platz hat schlägt
die nordrhein-westfälische
Schulministerin heute vor sie verspricht
Abhilfe
es gibt natürlich immer die Anschaffung
von Containern wo dann entsprechend
Schulunterricht stattfinden kann das ist
ganz unterschiedlich dass es wirklich
bedingt wie diese Situation tatsächlich
vor Ort ist die sichtbaren Schäden sind
das eine doch wenn Kinder ihr zu Hause
oder Angehörige verloren haben wird es
auch deshalb erstmal kaum normalen
Unterricht geben können in Schleiden in
der Eifel fordert man Unterstützung von
Psychologen weil wir gerade auch aus den
sehr jungen Kinder
Jahrgängen gemeldet wurden die haben
Angst davor das macht den Zaun sollte
die wollen nicht nach Hause weil sie
sagen sich kommen da nicht mehr raus
Mama und das sind eben Sachen da müssen
einfach Fachleute ran da müssen die
Eltern unterstützt werden und dann
müssen auch die Lehrer unterstützt
werden das ist ganz klar sie tun alles
um ihren Schülerinnen und Schülern den
Schulstart zu ermöglichen auch weil sie
wissen wie wichtig nun für die Kinder
ein Stück Normalität ist
absolut und damit weiter zum Sport
Kristin Olympia heißt das genau
Deutschland hat nun endgültig einen
neuen Star im Schwimmsport Florian
Wellbrock der Doppelweltmeister kraulte
auch bei Olympia zu zwei Medaillen nach
Bronze im Becken Gold im Freiwasser
äußerst souverän 10 km lang
dieser Sieg eine historische Leistung
Florian Wellbrock gewinnt unter extrem
Bedingungen das erste deutsche
freiwassergold überhaupt für mich
persönlich ist das glaube ich so ein
bisschen mein Sommermärchen heute 10 km
am frühen Morgen bei 30 Grad
Wassertemperatur in der Bucht vor Tokio
da gilt es frisch und wach zu bleiben
Wellbrock schwimmt auf Angriff von Weg
immer 30-32 Schwimmzüge pro Minute bis
auf einen späten Angriff der Konkurrenz
schwimmt er allein am Ende noch mal 25
Sekunden raus
ich habe schon gemerkt dass die ersten
Runden für mich eigentlich sehr locker
waren und wenn ich dahin geguckt habe
habe ich gesehen dass die anderen Jungs
ein bisschen Probleme hatten es ist sein
Rennen Florian Wellbrock feiert sein
erstes olympisches Gold und das erste
für die Männer im Schwimmen seit 33
Jahren
jubeltrainen und Erleichterung auch bei
den Kanten Max hoff und Jakob Schopf
Silber für das sogenannte
generationenboot nach einem beherzten
Rennen im Zweierkajak ein
hochemotionaler Tag für zwei Kanuten
nach dem silbererfolg kullerten beim
22-Jährigen Jakob Schopf die Tränen und
auch der 16 Jahre ältere Max hoff war
nach dem letzten großen Rennen seiner
Karriere sichtlich bewegt
ich glaube er ist auch zufrieden und ich
bin dankbar dafür dass ich das noch mal
erleben durfte und
mit 38 Jahren ist auch keine
Selbstverständlichkeit und
will eigentlich auf den Weg unterstützt
hat
in einem kanukrimi lieferten sie sich
ein packendes Rennen mit den späteren
Olympiasiegern westhäusen Krien aus
Australien nur 0,3 Sekunden fehlten zu
Gold für Oldie hoff ist es bereits die
dritte olympische Medaille für Schopf
die erste
die deutschen Tischtennisspielerinnen
haben dagegen die erhoffte
Bronze-Medaille verpasst sie unterlagen
im kleinen Finale Hongkong mit eins zu
drei Sätzen und auch die deutschen
hockey-männer gingen leer aus erstmalig
seit 21 Jahren bei Olympia durch das 4:5
gegen Indien im Spiel um Platz 3
stolz und glücklich zeigte sich dagegen
Carolin Schäfer nach ihrem siebten Platz
im Siebenkampf es fühle sich an wie eine
Medaille sagte sie zufrieden Gold ging
an die belgerin tiam und die Zehnkämpfer
sind auch durch König der Athleten von
Tokio ist Damien Warner aus Kanada mit
exzellenten 9.018 Punkten Weltmeister
Niklas Kaul hatte ja wegen einer
Sprunggelenksverletzung gestern
aufgegeben ja und mehr Olympia wie
gewohnt jetzt schon später im heute
journal ich habe es fast gar nicht
vielen Dank Chris die wir freuen uns
drauf das Wetter noch morgen kommt die
nächste Welle mit Gewittern dabei auch
wieder Starkregen und Hagel alle Details
dazu gleich von östen Tally die Kollegin
Marietta Slomka hat das heute journal
heute schon um 21 Uhr von uns allen hier
danke dass ihr dabei waren bis morgen
aber erst wünsche ich Ihnen einen
angenehmen Abend tschüss
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter noch ein Tag mit
Schauern und Gewittern und zwar Morgen
erwartet uns und mit diesem Tief und
dessen Kaltfront werden diese Gewitter
dann ausgelöst so ein Band was uns
erreicht ansonsten ist es weiterhin heiß
über Griechenland und über der Türkei
auf der Vorderseite dieses gesamten
Komplexes mit den Teams wird weiterhin
diese heiße Luft herangeführt ja und in
der Nacht brechen die schauen Gewitter
im Südosten zusammen neu erreichen uns
in den Frühstunden von Westen her sonst
ist etwas Regen im Norden dabei meist
ist es dann trocken und die Temperaturen
sinken auf 10 Grad nach Osten hin und 15
Grad ganz im Westen sowie an den Küsten
morgen eine Tagesverlauf also Schauer
und Gewitter die aufziehen und zwar wie
auf einem Band eingereiht von Nordwest
nach Südost ja im Südwesten lockert es
wieder auf mit sonnigen Abschnitten und
das bei Temperaturen von 24 25 Grad im
Osten und 19° nach Westen hin am Samstag
neue shower teils kräftige Gewitter von
Westen her im Osten Deutschlands bis 27
Grad und erstmal noch trocken damit ein
schöner Abend